[Música]
al menos dos jóvenes de 15 y 18 años han
perdido la vida en medio de las
protestas contra el nuevo gobierno
peruano los manifestantes condenan el
proceso contra el expresidente Pedro
Castillo al tiempo que piden la renuncia
de la presidenta Dina boluarte y el
adelanto de las elecciones
el volcán de fuego en el centro de
Guatemala entró En fase de erupción
generando columnas de ceniza de 5000
metros sobre el nivel del mar las
autoridades informaron que hay un flujo
de lava de 800 metros y no se descartan
nuevas avalanchas del volcán
con éxito amerizó en aguas del océano
Pacífico cerca de las costas mexicanas
de Baja California la cápsula orión
parte de la misión espacial no tripulada
artemis 1 una prueba importante de Cara
a futuras misiones tripuladas con
destino a la luna
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano y de Qatar soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en Perú donde ya
son al menos dos los muertos tras las
protestas en la ciudad de andahuaylas en
la región sur andina donde por segundo
día los manifestantes salieron a las
calles para condenar el proceso contra
el expresidente Pedro castillo y pedir
el adelanto de elecciones grupos de
manifestantes bloquearon la carretera
Panamericana Norte en dos localidades
del departamento de Lima entre los
reclamos está la renuncia de la
presidenta boluarte
no tienen nada de valor ustedes
golpistas mi pueblo de Apurímac está
luchando en pie de lucha por este pueblo
señor y no Volverte le pido que renuncie
no somos ni comunistas nada Somos el
pueblo organizado que queremos una
nación libre de corrupción que nos
permita sacar y salir de este
subdesarrollo de este colonialismo que
seguimos viviendo en Guatemala el volcán
de fuego continúa su erupción que inició
el sábado a pesar del helado y las
columnas de cenizas las autoridades no
ordenaron evacuaciones pero sí cerraron
algunas carreteras los habitantes están
alerta por si empeora la situación con
el volcán que mató a 215 personas en
2018 Ramiro cué Barberena nos cuenta más
Este es el volcán de fuego en Guatemala
durante el fin de semana reactivó su
actividad con una nueva fase de erupción
que incluyó flujos de lava explosiones y
una columna de cenizas de un kilómetro
según las autoridades los civiles están
alerta y preparados pero mantienen la
calma
Entonces tenemos ya listo en nuestra
mochila de 72 horas
de alguna emergencia pero en sí la
población ya está como acostumbrada de
vivir de vivir esto ya lo mira en esto
como si fuera normal el volcán de fuego
uno de los más activos en Centroamérica
tiene un antecedente trágico en 2018 su
erupción provocó la muerte de 319
personas y desde entonces las
autoridades toman mayores precauciones
la verdad que ahora las autoridades con
lo que pasó en el 2018 ahora sí ya se
ponen más alertas están más activos
verdad Porque yo en realidad sí he visto
de que este volcán en cuanto menos uno
se lo espera empieza su actividad no el
gobierno todavía no emitió la orden de
evacuar los asentamientos que están
alrededor del volcán pero se toman
recaudos por los desprendimientos que
salen del cráter
la erupción de volcán ubicado a 35
kilómetros al suroeste de la capital ha
despertado oscuro recuerdos en el país
centroamericano pero se espera que no
sea necesario ejecutar las evacuaciones
preventivas
vamos a catar Porque nuestro enviado
especial Juan pupiales nos trae los
detalles de la próxima jornada del
torneo esto tras el descanso de este
domingo marcado aún por la sorpresa de
la clasificación de Marruecos que dejó
por fuera Portugal y la victoria de
Francia sobre Inglaterra
Argentina y Croacia comenzaron este
domingo a entrenar de manera completa
pensando en esa primera semifinal que
vamos a tener en esta copa mundo de
Qatar 2022 por su parte de Marruecos la
gran revelación del certamen los
primeros africanos en avanzar hasta una
instancia de semifinales estuvieron el
día libre Mientras tanto Francia los
vigentes campeones del mundo estuvieron
realizando una sesión de recuperación
después de esa Victoria en cuartos de
final contra Inglaterra el combinado
galo que ya sabe que contará el
miércoles en la semifinal contra los
marroquíes con la presencia del
presidente Emmanuel macron Esta visita
la del mandatario francés que se produce
en momentos de tensión entre los
anfitriones y los organismos
comunitarios el Ministerio de exteriores
de Qatar que emitió un comunicado en
donde dicen rechazar que se los asocie
con cualquier Mala conducta esto después
de que un juez de Bruselas detuviera a
cuatro personas por un presunto
escándalo de corrupción dentro del
parlamento europeo entre esos cuatro
detenidos Incluyendo a la vicepresidenta
a la griega Eva Caeli tras ganar uno
cero a Portugal En los cuartos de final
del mundial Marruecos entró en la
historia del fútbol a convertirse en el
primer país africano en llegar a la
semifinal Este triunfo también es el de
reggae y el entrenador Franco marroquí
de 47 años que creció al sur de París y
llegó al frente de la selección a menos
de tres meses del inicio del mundial
imposible imaginar un mejor comienzo
para wallet regrágic que llegó a la
cabeza de la selección marroquí apenas
tres meses antes del puntapié inicial
del mundial a su llegada Los Leones del
Atlas han dado un giro desde entonces se
ha multiplicado las hazañas venciendo a
gigantes europeos como Portugal España y
Bélgica
puedes tener menos talento menos
cualidades menos dinero pero si quieres
si trabajas si luchas Si crees puedes
creo que todo el mundo está ahora del
lado de Marruecos Ojalá
y es un Franco marroquí hizo la mayor
parte de su carrera en Francia y obtuvo
allí sus diplomas de entrenador entre
2001 y 2009 también jugó 45 veces con
Marruecos en 2012 su país de origen le
ofreció su primer trabajo como técnico
una estrategia que valió la pena 10 años
después Hoy es el primer entrenador en
llevar a un equipo africano hasta
semifinales de un mundial hasta ahora
hacemos feliz a nuestro pueblo hacemos
feliz a un continente hacemos feliz del
mundo árabe creo que sabes un poco
cuando miras a Rocky Balboa quiere ser
Rocky porque él es el que viene de abajo
Así que aquí estamos un poco como Rocky
en este mundial
de los 26 jugadores del equipo 14
nacieron fuera de Marruecos
fundamentalmente en Países Bajos Bélgica
España y también en Francia esa Francia
a la que los Leones del Atlas se
enfrentarán el miércoles en semifinales
quizás el último paso antes de alcanzar
su sueño el de llegar a la final del
mundial de fútbol
delegaciones de países africanos
llegaron a Estados Unidos antes de la
Cumbre de líderes África Estados Unidos
en la que se espera que el presidente
Joe biden anuncie el apoyo
estadounidense a la admisión de la unión
africana en el g20 como miembro
permanente la iniciativa llega tras las
peticiones del presidente de la unión
africana y del presidente de senegal
makizal y también del mandatario de
Sudáfrica civil rama fosa justamente esa
última nación es el único miembro
africano 20 la unión africana está
compuesta por 55 estados miembros
el domingo la cápsula no tripulada orión
de la operación arte de mizuno volvió a
la tierra tras casi un mes de viaje en
el espacio es la primera prueba para
poder enviar astronautas a la luna en
2025 algo que supondría enormes avances
en investigaciones espacial Alba Santana
tiene los detalles
26 días después de su lanzamiento al
espacio la NASA lo consiguió la cápsula
orión volvió a la tierra y amerizó en el
océano Pacífico cerrando el primer
capítulo de la operación artemis 1
[Música]
desde la tranquilidad del espacio a las
aguas tranquilas del Pacífico el último
capítulo del viaje de la NASA a la luna
llega su cierre orión de vuelta en la
tierra la hora oficial del amerizaje las
11:40 y 30 segundos
la nave no tripulada entró a la
atmósfera terrestre a más de 39 mil
kilómetros por hora probando uno de los
objetivos del viaje que la cápsula podía
hasta 2760 grados Celsius al entrar en
la atmósfera y chocar con las moléculas
de aire
junto al éxito imágenes memorables por
la ventana de orión una tierra cada vez
más grande y silencio abrumador ahora el
programa artemis sucesor de Apolo está
un poco más cerca de su objetivo volver
a llevar astronautas a la luna después
de 50 años
vamos a ir de vuelta a la luna arte
mizuno una misión con la que muchos han
llegado a preguntarse Por qué volver a
la Luna si la NASA ya consiguió llegar
hasta allí pero lo cierto Es que artemis
1 artemis 2 y artemis 3 que será la
misión que llevará a cuatro astronautas
a la luna en 2025 va mucho más allá se
espera que los astronautas se
acostumbren a vivir en el espacio y
desarrollan ciencia y tecnología para un
objetivo mucho más grande poder enviar a
los primeros Humanos a marte Marte
todavía está muy lejos será sobre la
década de 2030 yo ya estaré retirado
pero creo que ocurrirá el final de este
primer vuelo coincide con una fecha muy
especial el 50 aniversario del Apolo 17
la última vez que los astronautas de la
NASA caminaron por la luna y ahora un
poco más cerca de volver a hacerlo
Así finalizamos esta informativa ustedes
Gracias por su sintonía
[Música]